[Music]
the distinction which was made between
actual spirit and spirit that knows
itself as spirit
or between itself consciousness and quas
self-consciousness
is superseded in the spirit that knows
itself in its truth
its consciousness and its
self-consciousness are
on the same level but in as religion
here is to begin with immediate this
distinction has not yet returned into
spirit
what is posited is only the notion of
religion in this the essence is
self-consciousness which is conscious of
being all truth and contains
all reality within that truth this
self-consciousness has
as consciousness itself for object
spirit
which to begin with has an immediate
knowledge of itself as thus to itself
spirit in the form of immediacy
and the determinateness of the form in
which it appears to itself is that of
mere being
this being it is true is filled neither
with sensation nor
manifold material nor with any other
kind of one-sided moments purposes and
determinations
it is filled with spirit and is known by
itself to be all truth and reality
such filling is not identical with its
shape
spirit essence is not identical with its
consciousness
spirit is actual as absolute spirit only
when it is
also for itself in its truth as it is in
its certainty of itself
or when the extremes into which as
consciousness
it parts itself are explicitly for each
other in the shape of spirit
the shape which spirit assumes as object
of its consciousness remains filled by
the certainty of spirit
as by its substance through this content
the object is saved from being degraded
to pure
objectivity to the form of negativity of
self-consciousness
spirit's immediate unity with itself is
the basis or pure
consciousness within which consciousness
parts asunder
into the duality of subject and object
in this way
spirit shut up within its pure
self-consciousness does not exist in
religion
as the creator of a nature in general
what it does create
in this movement are its shapes qua
spirits
in which together constitute the
completeness of its manifestation
and this movement itself is the genesis
of its complete reality
through its individual aspects or
through its incomplete shapes
paragraph 682 begins by
talking about something that has not yet
been achieved
in this religion section but is but is
going to be something that we're aiming
at
eventually and there's there's more to
be said about that there's there's more
to the story but
we'll get to that in a moment you notice
that there's
a key thing happening just about you
know five
sentences in what is posited is only the
notion of religion so whenever we see
only the notion that's an
important flag for us it doesn't have to
be a red flag it could be any flag you
like right
nerdy big if right means that we have
something that is not yet developed
it's basically you could substitute
there we only have the idea
of religion we don't have the actuality
the fully developed actuality of it
because we actually do have a lot of
actuality in the sense of vehicle
how things how things are in in religion
in its practice and in the way people
believe in
religious communities in in its
historical form
but we don't yet have the fully
developed
because or concept or notion we have
you could say the bear it would be
another way of saying instead of just
saying only the
the if we have the naked the bear the
underdeveloped concept or notion
and so what he's talking about at the
start is is not yet
attained so what is he talking about he
says this distinction that we made
between
actual spirit and spirit that knows
itself as spirit
is superseded in the spirit that knows
itself
in its truth now
knowing itself in its truth for hegel
that's something that is going to have
to be developed
right we're going to have to attain to
that we begin with certainty right
spirit certain of itself spirit that
knows its truth
spirit that is certain of its own truth
that's what we're
trying to attain and that's going to
come at the end of this
this long part of the phenomenology
so the other thing that he says here
where he says between actual spirit
right vehicle
is geist and spirit that knows itself is
spirit
and he says or between itself now here's
where
it's quite interesting consciousness
and qua self-consciousness
so spirit hasn't left
consciousness and self-consciousness
behind as a matter of fact what we've
seen
throughout the spirit section throughout
the reason section is that
these are ways of further developing
self-consciousness so self-consciousness
in relation to
the other of course although here it's
going to be a bit different
and consciousness consciousness of its
object we can correlate these if we want
to be very schematic to the reason and
spirit section
but within each of those long sections
there's a lot of development of
both of these isn't there so he he goes
on and he says
it's consciousness and its
self-consciousness
are on the same level so
instead of self-consciousness being
above and consciousness being below
they're on the same level
they have to be somehow brought together
how is that going to happen again we'll
we'll get to that in a bit
so coming back to this what does this
notion of religion
give us well he says religion here is to
begin with
immediate immediate meaning unmediated
right or mittelbach so
we have to sketch out the mediations and
as a matter of fact
this is a little bit of a digression but
when when hegel talks about something
being
immediate by now you know okay there's
always more to the story
so there's there's really two sides to
this that work together part of it is
uncovering the structures
where there is mediation going on where
something is not so
cut and dried as it appears at the
beginning but
like i said there's more to the story
there's other things happening
and now we make those evident the other
thing is sometimes we introduce
mediation
as well so as the phenomenologist we can
be witnessing mediation we can also be
as the phenomenologist watching the
agency seeing somebody
introduce mediation and these play off
of each other and so this is going to be
quite quite important
so he tells us that this distinction has
not yet returned into spirit
what we have what is posited is only the
notion of religion
in this the essence is
self-consciousness right so
i mentioned you know usually when we
have self-consciousness
we're thinking about our relation to the
other
and we go all the way back to the early
self-consciousness section
where self-consciousness only is in
relation to another
so there is another wanting this but at
this point in time
the other is is me the other is my my
own
self he says this is conscious of being
all truth and contains all reality
within that truth and that you know if
you think about religious believers
that may strike you as a little bit
incongruous
depending on you know what kind of
religious believers you're you're
running into if you're running into
people who think that
because they have had some sort of
religious teaching or conversion
they know everything well that that
could be you know like
you know a false consciousness of all
certainty all truth
all everything all reality because
they're full of crap
right and all you actually usually have
to do is
quote things from their own religion
that they
haven't taken stock of and you know it
readily becomes apparent
you know the people who are like well
you know the bible says and you're like
well the bible also says stuff about
people who you know
lie about how much they know and behave
like a bunch of jackasses and how
you know they're gonna go down to hell
and stuff like that
so i i don't know if you're if you're
using that as the index the proxy for
how
how much you embody reality and truth
and all these great things
maybe maybe you need to read a little
bit more or study a bit more right
so there's that but the ordinary
religious person
i would say doesn't actually behave that
way instead it's there's something else
and that's not me it could be a big o
other as it was in the unhappy
consciousness
and that's what embodies all all truth
right
so he says this self-consciousness has
as consciousness itself for object and
there's another thing too right
so self-consciousness does have itself
as object
even way back in the self-consciousness
section but it also has other for object
so again where has the other gone
he goes on and he says spirit which to
begin with
has an immediate knowledge of itself
is thus to itself spirit in the form of
immediacy and the determinateness of the
form in which it appears
to itself is that of a mere being
now there's a little bit of a
translation issue here that i want to
i want to signal call your attention to
he talks about spirit in the form of
immediacy
the german there is form right so
same german and english word being used
there
immediately after that miller translates
a word
as form which is not form but rather
gestalt which should be shape right so
there's a
it's a little bit misleading so let's
read it the way it should be
red here we go
spirit which to begin with has an
immediate knowledge of itself as thus to
itself spirit in the form of immediacy
and the determinateness of the
shape in which it appears to itself
is that of mere being so the gestalt the
the formation the structure
the object in this case in which it
appears
is mere being mere being is or being
zion is never all that great for for
hegel instead we want you know concept
or spirit
or all these other things that we could
substitute for
it and so religion is in a certain way
grasping itself in a very simplistic
and objective way something that could
be maybe put into
a comparative religion textbook as well
or a wikipedia article
here's what hinduism is right you read
it down
and there's something there and it
conveys some information but it
you know in a hegelian sense it's very
immediate it's saying this is just what
here's its being right and the lived
reality of a religion is way way more
complex even reading the
texts of a religion things are never so
simple
as the encyclopedia entry on it
so what have we got going on then
here we have this nice long discussion
and i think it can be helpful for us to
put these things in relation to each
other
he tells us this being the being
of religion the way in which spirit is
grasping itself
it is true is filled neither with
sensation
nor a manifold material right nor with
any other kind of one-sided moments
purposes and determination so he's using
this word
if woolen and he's going to use this
as a verb first and then he's going to
talk about it in a substantive way
as right
and he says that it's not filled it's
not
it's not given it all of its
determinancy you could say
although it is given a lot of
determinacy um
through sensations and fin doing the
things that we
we sense so like looking at an idol for
example
uh in a temple manifold material
manifold stuff right
sorry in the german uh stuff just
you know things matter that's been
been put in front of us these could be
like rituals
these could be texts these could be the
garments the priest is wearing
these could be the flowers brought
before the deity could be anything you
want right
one-sided moments purposes and
determination
so this word one-sided is is very
important hegel doesn't like things to
be one-sided
as a matter of fact a lot of german
philosophers don't einstein
is usually a pejorative term it means
you've left stuff out
and you're focusing too much just on on
this aspect
of something and so moments
that can be all sorts of things right
that's a rather abstract term
purposes you know goals
ideas that one has in mind in say
worshipping
or repenting or doing any of the things
that we might call religious acts
and then determinations uh the way
things are actually
done the way things are are produced
so these exist these are part of
religion
these are not what is actually filling
the
shape of religion instead
he talks about this filling this erfulum
which is not identical with the gestalt
not identical with the
shape he tells us that
it's it's filled here we go with spirit
and known by itself to be all truth and
reality
this is a little bit different than just
postulating to be all all truth in
reality all
var height and vertical right there's
something more
happening here this is again it's not
not yet realized but this is what the
promise
is and then we have the shape and he
tells us
that the shape the gestalt itself uh
it's not identical with the filling it
says spirit qua essence is not identical
with its consciousness
spirit is actual as absolute spirit only
when it is
also for itself in its truth as it is in
its certainty of itself
or when the extremes into which is
consciousness it parts itself are
explicitly for itself in the shape of
spirit that's going to happen later on
but then he says the shape which spirit
assumes is object of its consciousness
remains filled by the
certainty of spirit as by its substance
so the gestalt
the actual form that we can talk about
in the phenomenology
is filled by the certainty and substance
of
spirit and then he says through this
content
the object is degree is saved from being
degraded to pure objectivity to the form
of negativity of self-consciousness
and here you can imagine a religious
person
you know who's engaged in religious life
which is probably part of
a community's life right hegel is called
ethical life as well
going through the motions doing the
actions finding some meaning in that and
saying
what's going on here there's more
there's more happening here than what i
can
adequately describe more than what i'm
feeling more than what i'm
thinking i am engaged with the divine
how can i
actually conceptualize this it's not
just in the rituals or the material
artifacts
or the community itself there's so
there's a sort of
you know vague hint that that there's
something
really worth grasping here it's not pure
objectivity
and this is the form of negativity of
self-consciousness going all the way
back to stuff in the preface
so he says spirit's immunity unity with
itself is the basis or pure
consciousness
within which consciousness parts asunder
it splits itself up in this way spirit
shut up within its pure
self-consciousness does not exist
in religion as the creator of nature in
general now here's where we get to
something interesting
we've been talking about this very
general thing right and now he says
what we actually have is a creation of a
whole bunch of gestalton
a whole bunch of shapes and he calls
these
shapes qua spirits which together
constitute the completeness of its
manifestation
so when we get to the end we've gotten
through this completeness
of all of these shapes and the process
of auf haven sublation however you want
to talk about it
has been carried out so that there is
something happening at the end of
religion that took into account the
stuff that was happening earlier
in religion and he says this movement
itself is the genesis
of its com or verdun right of its
complete reality through the individual
aspects through its
incomplete shape so even though at you
know with given religions given shapes
of religion we don't have the totality
of developed
and actual spirit we do if we consider
it as a
whole and that's what this whole section
is supposed to be doing
the first reality of spirit is the
notion of religion itself
or religion as immediate and therefore
natural religion
in this spirit knows itself as its
object in a natural or immediate shape
the second reality however is
necessarily that in which spirit knows
itself
in the shape of a superseded natural
existence or of the self
this is therefore the religion of art
for the shape
raises itself to the form of the self
through the creative activity of
consciousness
whereby this beholds in its object its
act or the self
finally the third reality overcomes the
one-sidedness of the first two
the self is just as much an immediacy as
the immediacy is the self
if in the first reality spirit in
general is in the form of consciousness
and in the second in that of
self-consciousness in the third
it is the form of the unity of both it
has the shape
of being in and for itself and when it
is thus conceived
as it is in and for itself this is the
revealed religion
but although when this spirit has indeed
attained its true shape
yet the shape itself and the picture
thought are still the unvanquished
aspect
from which spirit must pass over into
the notion
in order wholly to resolve their in the
form of objectivity
in the notion which equally embraces
within itself its own opposite
it is then that spirit has grasped the
notion of itself just as we now have
first grasped it
and its shape or the element of its
existence being the notion
is spirit itself
in paragraph 683 we see the structure
of the religion section set out with
some justification for
why it's arranged in this triadic form
and we also get to see you could say a
depiction not
only of the totality of the religion
section
and its end but also where we're going
from there
and so so let's begin with that because
that's quite interesting
this is at the very end of the paragraph
he says that in revealed religion spirit
has attained
its true shape but the shape itself
and the picture thought for stella right
representation
are still the unvanquished aspect from
which spirit must pass over
into the notion the begriff the concept
in order wholly to resolve they're in
the form of objectivity and the notion
which
equally embraces within itself its own
opposite it is then that spirit has
grasped the notion of itself just as we
now have first grasped it and in its
shape or the element of its existence
being the notion of spirit itself he is
talking there
about absolute knowing and about the
culmination
of the entire phenomenology of spirit
and religion
is the the road that we now have to
traverse
to get to revealed religion which is
going to be
the launching pad for that we're going
to be there
we're going to have absolute knowing but
in a
deficient effective form that of
you know a particular shape that of
representation rather than the concept
and notice how far we've come
just from the last paragraph where we
began with the
you know the mirror notion the mirror
because
of religion this empty thing and now
we're at
the notion itself of spirit
which is grasping itself as containing
its opposite
and you know all of that so that's still
yet to be attained but we
we now see the path ahead and the path
ahead hegel is sketching for us a sort
of
map you could say so there's three uh
parts to it right he calls these
realities of spirit
these are ways in which spirit is
actual real present in the world
and present in the form of religion so
we have
three kinds of of religion natural
religion religion of art
consli religion right and then
revealed religion religion that is not
just revealed but also
revealing and i do want to say one
thing we're going to talk a little bit
more about this in the next paragraph
where he's uh telling us some incredibly
important things about the
development history of religions and his
phenomenology of religions but i do want
to point out
that it's not as if there's like these
lock-step
stages where you've got this kind of
religion
and it's only focused on natural objects
objects of the environment
that have been put brought into a temple
and they don't have any aspect of
you know artistic consciousness or
revelation going on that's nonsense and
any interpretation
of what hegel is doing that would try to
construe it that way
is off base what he's saying is that
there are certain things that
predominate certain things certain
motifs
that are absolutely central and the
other things
while they play a role they are not
playing the essential
role right they are not the most
important
part of it they're not visibly you could
say
so you know natural religion there's
something going on there and how does he
understand that well he says we begin
with again the notion
of religion the the bare idea of it
and he tells us this is religion as
immediate
and therefore natural religion
we'll talk about why it's natural
religion in the next paragraph and he
says in this
spirit knows itself as an object
or in a natural or immediate shape so
you know it knows itself
in terms of something like
a crystal it knows itself in terms of a
stone it knows itself in terms of a
plant or an
animal it knows itself in terms of light
it knows itself in terms of natural
forces and so there are some religions
that hegel thinks are more
centered on that aspect of religion and
there's there's a development that
that goes on there going through
different shapes different gestalton
right
then we have a religion that he calls
um you can call it religion of art or
religion
as art kunst lika religion
um queenst is more than just fine art
you know
but we are going to be associating this
with like sculpture
and with epic poetry and you know what
it is that we as human beings
produce and you notice that the gods or
the the god itself
as depicted in this is in in you know
forms that are like ourselves so he
tells us that the second reality
is that in which spirit knows itself in
the shape of and now this is very
important
it's not just that we like to make
pictures of apollo
and we say oh well you know paulo is
probably like us and you know maybe
apollo's a good god more or less but
there's also like aries the god of war
then there's also nice you know athena
who's also a goddess of war but in a
different way
than you know the indiscriminate killing
on the battlefield and bloodlust
of that bad guy and then we've got you
know aphrodite the spirit
uh or or you know goddess of love
lust sexuality you know we're not just
doing that
well those are important aspects of
human existence
there's something more going on here
superseded
natural existence the human
is in some respects set apart from the
world
and the other animals and you know
nature itself we
are we are a weird weird
animal so to speak right and this is
something that you see in philosophy you
know being rational
doesn't mean that suddenly everything
falls into place for us
we're way more messed up than any other
animal is we
change the environment in ways that
others don't we
introduce new ideas and so this is part
of
that second form of religion he calls
this the religion of art
and he tells us the shape raises itself
to the form of what the self
through the creative activity of
consciousness
whereby this beholds in its object its
act or the self
knowing the self is not just navel
gazing
it's knowing yourself through what you
do
it's also knowing yourself in what those
other cells are doing too that are not
yourself but
in which you exist in some sort of
relation maybe those other cells are
devils or
bad gods or whatever whatever they
happen to be right
and so here we could talk about the
olympian gods and the whole pantheon
and you know hegel doesn't do this but
maybe we can extend this to other
you know pantheons as well
he goes on then he talks about the third
and he says the third reality
overcomes the one-sidedness
of the first two as i just pointed out
in the last paragraph whenever hegel
says one-sidedness
be on the alert because one-sidedness is
never good right so each of these
is one-sided this somehow brings them
together
in revealed religion and so it's
bringing together the
immediacy the naturalness and the
creativeness the reflectiveness of the
the second so he says uh the self is
just as much an immediacy
as the immediacy is the self so that's
an interesting thing to say
right instead of saying here's a great
example of
why you shouldn't read hegel as thesis
antithesis synthesis you know and then
we prepare for yet another one
that silly you know nonsense not
hegel three step that people always
bring forward
you can see three here so you know okay
i can understand why that could come up
but notice what's happening in the
overcoming one-sidedness
is it's simply people often say oh it's
determinate negation you know you begin
with
one thing then you negate it then you
negate that other thing and you get the
third thing
that's somehow bringing them together no
this is this is sort of like a chiasm
you know this x figure in rhetoric
where the self is immediacy right the
self brings in this factor here
the immediacy brings in this factor here
this is more complicated
than what people like to portray as
going on
so he says if in the first reality
spirit in general is in the form of
consciousness
and the second that is
self-consciousness in the third it's the
form
of the unity of both it has the shape of
being
in and for itself when it is thus
conceived
as it is and in and for itself this is
the revealed religion
um now that's so that's a bit of a
stretch is that what we normally think
of as revealed religion that it's
you know spirit showing itself in and
for itself not usually
right but we'll get there in that
section what is important here though is
is trying to wrap your head around what
it is
for so consciousness right it's
conscious of an object that it in a
certain sense doesn't recognize itself
in
self-consciousness recognizing itself
within this
this you know set of objects that are
others that are selves
and then a unity of consciousness and
self-consciousness what would that be
well this is what
spirit is when it's fully developed
so the revealed religion which is going
to be you know a lot of heartbreak and
and a lot of labors along the way uh is
ultimately supposed to yield us this
this kind of unity here
and this is essentially where hegel is
ending this introductory section
we're now ready to move into natural
religion
you